en alsace en revanche le conseil
régional va dans le sens de l'histoire
et de la préservation de la planète il
vient d'annoncer une série de mesures en
faveur des énergies renouvelables
les particuliers qui installent une
pompe à chaleur dans leurs maisons
neuves ou anciennes recevront une somme
allant de 200 à 400 euros
ces appareils récupère la chaleur de la
terre ou de la nappe phréatique et ils
permettent de consommer trois fois moins
d'électricité s'estime boss verger
liabot plus dans la famille michel été
comme hiver on n'hésite pas à
s'installer par terre car ici la chaleur
vient du sol leur nouvelle maison est
chauffée grâce à une pompe à chaleur
géothermique ou lyon cette fois-ci
utiliser l'énergie écologique propre et
économique parce que lens maison nous
habitions nous avions chauffage fuel et
donc au prix du fuel actuellement girafe
ne sait plus très rentable donc c'est
pour ceux ci que nous avons préféré
opter pour la géothermie
pour cela il a fallu forer deux puits de
80 mètres de profondeur pour capter la
chaleur naturelle du sous-sol seule
partie visible ces tuyaux relié à une
pompe à chaleur qui restitue les
calories dans les planchers de la maison
un mode de chauffage économique
la facture est divisé par trois et aux
vertus écologiques
ce système permet également de limiter
fortement le
le dégagement de gaz à effet de serre
donc notamment le co2 et donc c'est
également l'un des objectifs
d'électricité de strasbourg c'est de
promouvoir justement les systèmes qui
permettent d'atteindre cet objectif
environnemental car ici les énergies
renouvelables sont une priorité
la région alsace à subventionner
l'installation de chauffe-eau solaire
avec succès elle devenue la première
région solaire de france après les
chaudières à bois
elle subventionne les pompes à chaleur
hauteur goutte de sang à 400 euros
la région souhaite vraiment être pilote
dans ce type d'opération il est vrai
qu'il existe des étangs de l'état de
l'inde m
je crois qu'il est important aussi que
les régions s'engagent à ce niveau là a
ajouté au crédit d'impôt cette
subvention permet de réduire le montant
de l'installation de 30 % car une faune
pas cher coûte cher environ 20000 euros
mais c'est un pari sur l'avenir